The reason that this volume doesn't work is because it's giving us a negative
value. For a quantity that we should be able to touch and feel, it's tangible.
And length and areas and volumes are usually positive. Let's see if we can
figure out why by using a real piece of paper again. After all, this is the
right size, so maybe if we try to make this box, we'll figure out what's going
wrong. Here's my ruler and my piece of paper and I'm going to measure in three
inches from each side and then in the other direction as well. Okay, so there's
one of the squares we should draw. Now let's draw the other three. Two squares,
and now potentially for the tricky ones. So here's the issue we have when I
tried to draw my boxes for the corners that I want to cut out. This length right
here is 3 inches, or x, the length of the square that I want to cut out. But you
can see that if I started to cut here, and actually cut down the whole length,
right there, I'm already cutting into an area that's supposed to be part of
another square that I'm going to, to cut out. This is a major issue. I'm not
going to have enough flaps left, or enough material left if I cut out all of
this. In fact, let's just do it to see what happens. Now I just have this strip
of paper and I can't make a box out of this.There are no flaps. I guess this has
something to do with what's going on. So for our 5 inch by 7 inch piece of
paper, what value must x, the cut length, not exceed in order for us to still be
able to have flaps that we can fold up and make this into a box? Just think back
on what the problem was before with the 3 in cut length, and use your common
sense. This is kind of a riddle. So, just think through and take your time.